[Musik]
guten tag frau mein name sind sie die
veranstalterin des flohmarkts ja wenn
ich ich bin vor lokalteil des tageblatts
darf ich ihnen ein paar fragen stellen
klar gerne wie sind sie auf die idee für
den flohmarkt gekommen ganz einfach man
kann nicht immer alles neu kaufen
hier wird recycelt gebrauchte
gegenstände werden hier nicht
weggeworfen sie wechseln den besitzer
das besondere hier ist ja das alles
umsonst ist warum wenn sie etwas
wegwerfen
da kommt sie doch auch kein geld dafür
oder das hier ist doch toll was hier
finde ich schön
frau konzertes entschuldigung was
wollten sie noch wissen